what's happening reject nation it's Greg
Alva here and I'm the artist formerly
known as John John and I are gonna check
out the trailer today for ocean's 8 with
a bunch of women who are late as their
women this time females usually pregnant
that's the risk of this heist is that
they're all pregnant in this heist
issues you got to make it you know they
all have to steal we're making fun of
the fact that another female people
might say when turning their nose of it
something like this
before we go into this wanted to give
another thank you to our video sponsors
over at Stardust Stardust is a great app
that allows you to do 30-second
reactions for any film TV show or
trailer we're on our way to passing 2300
followers on the app that's because we
use it consistently throughout the week
so I'm so glad that the community there
is growing a lot of your favorite
youtubers are using it I follow all them
you should too but more importantly if
we're the first ones to tell you
download the app and follow us first you
don't deserve it
patron of the day shout out to Erica
Tuesday keep a lookout for that
[Music]
I would just want to simple like I just
hold on a job make some friends
it's pretty sad cat why do you do this
she's rusty
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's a - fun James Court
[Music]
can't we just go to this
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Jamie oh they're just one of those weird
Warner Brothers endings well that's a
very Ocean's eleven Soderberg shot a lot
of those Zubin someone walking that's
very Ocean's eleven I'm very familiar
with the trilogy by Sir yeah it looks
like an oceans movie it looks ocean to
me the oceans movies are not exactly
something special to begin with other
than the first one the first one is very
special in my mind this looks like a
retread of that but with females they're
all movies more than their films to me
it looks like it has that vibe yeah like
slick kind of jazzy sort of sly vibe is
actually kind of surprised at how much I
was kind of transported back to that
style through this I feel like Gary Ross
kind of picked up the at least earmarks
of the franchise pretty pretty well well
I wish he was doing something a little
bit more uniquely distinct visually
other than doing what sort of work good
for three films because if I didn't know
Gary Ross's record something like this
looks like a Soderbergh movie yeah yeah
I don't know exactly how I feel about
that yet because part of me understands
like yeah uniformity this is a sequel
and a spinoff I get that they need to
look similar but at the same time yeah
it would be nice to breathe some new
blood into this and also for the story
yeah it just feels kind of like another
oceans movie so I'm like ah there's
gonna go steal something it's just
oceans movie with another with a
different cast which is actually fine
for notions but that's it yeah it's like
I don't know what else I would want this
isn't ghostbusters yeah where words like
nostalgia and monumental film that
they're rebooting with females that's
not that yeah I mean even Ocean's eleven
was a remake of another film of a Frank
Sinatra movie The Wrap movie yeah well
like but isn't like a household name so
yeah it's like doing this now and the
oceans films have always been a bunch of
clackers just taking it was Soderbergh
doing some cool slick direction and a
witty script so I'm not bothered by that
however there is a slight feeling could
use a little bit more difference a
little bit yeah does it even starts as
ocean's 11 starts off with George
Clooney
jail and like yeah I'm gonna have a good
live and then immediately it gets his
rusty which is Kate Blanchette here
start putting together a team and then
you find out that within the job there's
actually a bigger job that's more
important to Sandra Bullock's character
which is what it was or George Clooney
and Ocean's eleven and Cate Blanchett's
like you shouldn't be doing this when
we're working on a job it's the same
conversation rusty a George Clooney yeah
and that's the stuff it's like I don't
begrudge this movie for being very
similar to an oceans movie but yeah in
terms of the like I wish we could do
something a little bit more yeah you
know because I want this movie to
succeed generally speaking I like the
cast they've got together I think they
got some great actresses together I feel
like if you if you are unaware that this
is a spin-off and you call her ocean and
the trailer and stuff and you don't
establish as she's the sister I feel
like people will watch this trailer
going is this a remake of Ocean's eleven
but with female that's yeah that's the
issue with the trailer well it's not
made clear other than the one line
that's a throwaway so everyone is in the
family other than that which doesn't
make it 100% clear it's still my god
this is just a remake of oceans that's I
want to hit the sea maybe I don't mind
having a heist movie that's just a fun
movie with a bunch of really cool female
actresses hanging out and having a great
time it's just a lot of them feel like
they're feeling the art types of what
the male characters did and it's the
same plot of the one with a male
character yeah that's my main concern
with this basically is like I'm fine
with the concept I like the cast I like
the vibe I just yeah yeah I don't want
to be that thing where it's like oh I
remember what that looked like in
Ocean's eleven just switching out the
plot details and it's it is just a
trailer but I hope that the whole movie
doesn't rest on structure of Ocean's
eleven because you know it's still got
to be its own thing and I know that this
is a risky move or whatever you know it
should still be its own own movie if I
were to give one thing that I think it
still might do better is other than the
first and I still feel like the ocean is
12 and 13 the actors were literally like
treating like a like a sandler flick
they were just hanging out on set or not
that emotionally invested in the
material I don't even feel like I'm the
first one there strongly invested in
general I feel like they're just they're
doing a good job they seem like they
they are pretty confident there
yeah but in this one I feel like the
actors are bringing a lot more work into
the layers of their characters that's
the only that's something I think is a
little more apparent this time around
and I thought the comedy might be more
in front of our faces
yeah well this got me excited to meet
the characters like this this yeah
reminded me of the magic of like Oh
everybody gets an intro where you get to
see what there's and I mainly trying to
Sarah Paulsen and Mindy Kaling and this
is nice because it like to see what the
characters are actually gonna be like
like we've seen pictures of them hanging
out on the subway or whatever but you
know to get the vibe for what the
ensemble is gonna be like and what each
character is was something I like
oh cool like looks like a good specific
team it's reaffirming that these will
have distinct personalities amongst cast
which is what you want when you get this
level of actors so nobody's got to be on
cuz it doesn't look like Cate Blanchett
playing Cate Blanchett and doesn't know
where senator Brookes plane Sandra we're
playing characters I feel like where you
come this franchise where you come to
you want to be like the coolest version
of you that's cool you know who could
join the cast though oh dude Erica Terry
good Tuesday can join yes they need like
a an alts like punky because Erica is
the kind of that yeah great loss Spray
witty sarcastic but very intelligent and
artistic creative
oh yeah she'd be perfect actually no Joe
no that's because the shoutout yeah
Nueve comes around yes or no ere we go
but I can literally see her like having
some sarcastic banter back and forth
while like going into a vault and then
on her walk my favorite one yeah hottest
one she's hotter than all these
actresses
remember this Erica remember remember
Greg said that which means less yeah
anyway guys subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell you could download the Stardust app
and follow us today we are posting
regularly over there become a patron
eject today it's like a second YouTube
channel go there to find out what I
exactly mean by that